[Musica]
un pomeriggio
buon pomeriggio e bentrovati bellissima
bellissimo colpo d'occhio da qui devo
dire io sono una persona molto fortunata
sono una persona fortunata perché ho
passato gli ultimi 25 anni della mia
vita
un po come questa giornata che abbiamo
trascorso insieme con persone come
quelle che sono state sul palco fino a
questo momento come come loretta come e
dia come stamattina come come tutti gli
altri ma non è di questa fortuna che
voglio parlarvi
sono fortunato in realtà per un altro
motivo perché sono ipermetrope ora non
so e non vedo perché è un po buio ma c'è
qualche altro ipermetrope qui in sala
qualcuno qualche qualche mano beh non
abbiate timore perché l'ipermetropia
della quali voglio parlare è un
ipermetropia dello spirito quindi è
aperta a chiunque
che cos'è l'ipermetropia l'ipermetropia
è una condizione della vista per la
quale si fa molta fatica ad accomodare
lo sguardo sulle cose vicine risultano
sempre un po sfocate invece quelle
lontane quelle quelle molto in fondo
quale si vedono benissimo c'è uno
studioso americano si chiama paul sapho
che nel 1995 quando tutto il cambiamento
di cui si è discusso qui oggi doveva
praticamente ancora incominciare
raccontò una cosa interessante saffo
dice che quando ci sono dei grandi
mutamenti delle regolazioni l'attitudine
con la quale ci accostiamo essi è quella
della macro miopia
cosa significa significa che siamo
portati a vedere solo gli effetti
immediati gli effetti immediati di
solito sono degli effetti dirompenti
sono degli effetti che ci intimoriscono
c impauriscono
perché distruggono un equilibrio che
esisteva ma non erano ancora creato un
altro non si vede il nuovo e in fondo
invece di nuovo c'è perché poi queste
rivoluzioni questi cambiamenti producono
sempre nel lungo periodo dei cambiamenti
che migliorano in modo in cui siamo
abituati a vivere almeno fino adesso è
sempre stato così la comunicazione
un esempio che si fa sulla comunicazione
riguardo proprio a questi effetti a
breve termine confrontati con gli
effetti a lungo termine è quello
classico di un evento che si verificò
nel 1454 c'è qualcuno che sa cosa accade
nel 1454 oddio è vero complimenti non
l'avevo mai ricevuto a questa risposta
qualche altro a magonza un signore che
si chiama johannes gutenberg inventa i
caratteri mobili e ora fate conto che
tutti insieme ci si possa muovere sulla
macchina del tempo e andiamo nel 1454
siamo nell'officina di johannes scooter
quella sera quando lui sta riempendo la
42esima linea di quale libro che libro
era la bibbia perché io ad essere un
uomo bio e secondo voi johannes capiva
fino in fondo ciò che sarebbe venuto
dalla sua invenzione
no no e c'è qualcuno di voi che pensa
che l'invenzione dei libri sia stata
un'invenzione negativa per gli esseri
umani
no
eppure eppure uno degli effetti
collaterali preterintenzionale diremmo
della creazione della stampa fu che di
quelle famose bibbie ne sarebbero state
stampate 50 milioni
in 12 anni anzi 12 milioni
in 50 anni questo cosa significa che
improvvisamente effetto collaterale
nel momento in cui in un villaggio non
c'è più una sola bibbia ma ognuno di noi
né a casa una non c'è più bisogno di
andare in chiesa a sentire il parroco
che ce la spieghi dal pulpito ognuno a
casa sua a una bibbia la legge e la
interpreta il sapere si diffonde
l'interpretazione anche l'effetto
collaterale più fragoroso
dell'invenzione della stampa a caratteri
mobili sarà il protestantesimo gutenberg
di sicuro quella sera del 1454 non lo
sapeva
e ancora se ci spostiamo ancora più
avanti e dal cinquecento passiamo al
no due secoli dopo quella sera nel 1454
ma la stampa di livelli di pamphlet di
manifesti sarà uno dei motivi chiave per
i quali nel 1618 scoppia arriva a
ebollizione un pentolone che covava da
tempo e scoppia la guerra dei trent'anni
uno dei conflitti più sanguinosi della
civiltà pensate che tra il 1618 1648
nello scontro tra il sacro romano impero
da una parte e gli stati del nord
protestanti appunto solo in germania
periranno 12 milioni di persone
la circolazione delle idee gli effetti
preterintenzionale
eppure in questa sala tra di noi c'è
qualcuno che riterrebbe che sarebbe
stato meglio non averlo proprio
inventato il libro
no non credo perché non ci sarebbe stato
nemmeno tutto il resto
ed è stato così per ogni passaggio della
civiltà umana
addirittura se voi leggete il freddo di
platone a un certo punto platone lato ne
fa dire a un re egiziano al quale si
presenta una divinità gli fa dire guarda
ho capito tu divinità ha inventato la
scrittura ma la scrittura è una
fregatura perché perché l'unica cosa
viene importante per l'uomo che la
memoria nel momento in cui scriveremo le
cose ci sembrerà di saperle ma invece
non le sapremo davvero perché saranno da
una parte in un libro avremo un
illusione di sapere invece solo che sta
quel che sa nel nostro cervello e sapere
vero afferma questo re che in realtà e
platone stesso sappiamo sappiamo com'è
andata
ma perché perché la comunicazione è un
fattore così importante perché la
comunicazione è ciò che ha permesso all
homo sapiens di salire in cima alla
catena alimentare
lo spiega bene uno studioso harari in un
libro che si intitola appunto sapiens e
tra 70 mila e 30 mila anni fa un certo
punto succede che l'uomo passa
dall'essere nel mezzo della catena
alimentare
a esserne il signore signore di tutti
gli animali
cos'è che abilita tutto questo
linguaggio linguaggio complesso perché
perché tutti gli animali hanno telefono
le primitive di comunicazione sanno
sentire il pericolo intuiscono cosa sta
per accadere
a volte se lo comunicano anche ma la
complessità del linguaggio dell'uomo
consente appunto in quell'arco di tempo
non solo di effettuare delle
comunicazioni elementari ma di
cominciare ad effettuare delle
comunicazioni molto più elaborate ad
esempio non più solo l'idea che dietro
l'ansa del fiume cioè della selvaggina
ma che se siamo in gruppo ci possiamo
dividere in due alcuni vanno con una
rete gli altri passano da dietro la
collina salgono poi riscendono fanno del
rumore la selvaggina sarà spinta verso
il fiume è intrappolata e quelli con la
rete
la potranno cacciare e poi la sera la
sera quando quando si va a tutti davanti
al fuoco con la pancia piena e grazie al
fuoco
il cervello può lavorare perché prima
grana parte dell'intestino risucchiava
tutte le nostre energie perché quando si
consumava la carne cruda è un bel
problema per i denti ma anche per la
digestione e allora ecco che davanti al
fuoco il linguaggio complesso permette
di inventare i miti permette di
cominciare a elaborare le religioni cosa
sono i miti se ci pensate i miti sono le
storie sono una delle cose più potenti
che noi abbiamo per secoli gli stati
nazionali si sono retti su un mito la
derivazione divina del potere di un
sovrano assoluto alla favola una storia
e quali altri storia siamo stati in
grado di mettere insieme in una
complessità crescente quale altri
linguaggi e pensate ai codici giuridici
esiste una società a responsabilità
limitata
cos'è e alla finanza i default credit
swap
la moneta sono tutte fantasie sono
costruzioni complesse che noi via via
siamo stati in grado di edificare sulla
base delle quali la nostra civiltà è
progredita ecco perché
ecco perché toccare la comunicazione ed
è una pubblicazione non solo verbale non
solo scritta è una comunicazione che
oggi viaggia per bit anche il software è
un codice si scrive codice anche anche
il genoma ciò che fa sì che noi si sia
ciò che si è
è un insieme di informazioni un codice
una comunicazione la più importante che
c'è bene tutto questo è rivoluzionato
dalla connessione permanente dalla
velocità di scambio delle informazioni
dalla capacità di calcolo crescente dai
big data e via discorrendo
la nostra reazione di fronte a una cosa
cosi enorme probabilmente più grande di
qualsiasi altro cambiamento e la paura
la paura e la miopia abbiamo abbiamo il
naso schiacciato sulla pagina e quindi
mentre ci vorrebbero nuove elaborazioni
che andassero oltre gli stati
kikkio dicono negli stati nazionali
mentre ci vorrebbero più ponti e meno
muri i pochi ponti che abbiamo a volte
cadono e pensiamo a costruire nuovi muri
metterci vorrebbe più scienza adesso
spuntano quelli che dicono alla cina
mentre ci vorrebbe più coscienza critica
ciò che fa premio poi invece nelle
nostre decisioni più importanti sono
solo le percezioni perché in realtà se
il mondo è una nostra costruzione e in
gran parte lo è una nostra costruzione
e se lo è davvero come lo pensiamo come
lo vediamo la miopia rispetto all'inter
metropia può fare la differenza
c'è uno scienziato svedese che è morto
l'anno scorso purtroppo si chiamava o la
rosling forse qualcuno di voi lo conosce
ha scritto anche lui molti libri
interessanti ma ci sono anche diversi
filmati che lo riguardano in rete che ha
speso tutta la vita a cercare di
spiegare che in realtà le cose negli
ultimi 50 anni sono andate assai meglio
della percezione che noi ne abbiamo
alcuni fatti negli ultimi 50 anni la
povertà questo pianeta si è dimezzata
oggi la maggior parte della popolazione
vive in paesi a medio reddito
l'ottanta per cento dei bambini di un
anno è esposto a un qualche tipo di
vaccinazione
l'ottanta per cento dei cittadini del
pianeta ha un qualche accesso
all'elettricità
teniamoci questo non significa che va
tutto bene ci sono le diseguaglianze c'è
quel 20 per cento c'è un sacco di lavoro
da fare ma se lo guardiamo in questo
modo il mondo appare po diverso da come
da come siamo abituati a percepirlo
purtroppo in tutto questo c'è una
particolarità italiana perché perché la
paura ma che mondo è mondo non è solo un
atteggiamento naturale dell'uomo ma è
anche un mercato e il mercato e la paura
è utile è utile per motivi economici
spesso anche fomentati da noi
giornalisti che mettiamo nel sistema
polarizzazione odio bugia spesso dai
politici per potere la paura rende rende
perché noi siamo esseri umani e come ha
trovato
lo studio delle mighty le notizie false
o che ci intimoriscono sono condivise
sei volte più velocemente delle notizie
vere perché è colpa degli hacker russi
ha colpa dei bimbi macedoni che vogliono
fare un po di soldi in rete è colpa
degli algoritmi e dei social network no
siamo noi dipende da come siamo
costruiti noi dal fatto che siamo miopi
e non utilizziamo un po di lungimiranza
un po di ipermetropia oggi siamo portati
a pensare che il nostro paese d'italia
non abbia mai vissuto un momento così
diviso così polarizzato di odio di
incertezza 2018 sono esattamente 40 anni
da quando in questo paese venne rapito e
ucciso aldo moro
io voglio solo ricordare alle persone
che non hanno vissuto con gli anni che
tra il 1976 1980 in italia morirono 600
persone 3 mila furono ferite e ci furono
9673 atti di sangue 5 al giorno
davvero possiamo sostenere che questo il
più polarizzato è il più difficile
periodo della nostra storia
e allora e allora tutto ciò significa
che la cosa più rilevante di fronte a
cambiamenti che ci spiazzano perché
parliamoci chiaro diceva già george
bernard shaw l'unico cambiamento che ci
lascia tranquilli
l'unico essere umano che voglia davvero
un cambio è neonato bagnato tutti gli
altri tutti gli altri sono impauriti
sono molte
io per primo tutti noi siamo impauriti
dai cambiamenti e allora come dobbiamo
stare in questi cambiamenti con una
prospettiva un pochino più distante
se noi guardiamo alla storia del pianeta
e proviamo per il momento a raccoglierla
tutta in una giornata questi quattro
miliardi e mezzo di anni su una palla
sulla quale viaggiano tutti insieme
sparate nello spazio beh proviamo a
metterli in una giornata lo sapete
quando compaiono in questa giornata di 4
miliardi e mezzo di anni che ora dura 24
ore i dinosauri attorno alle 23 il
computer compaia compare attorno alle 23
59 59 internet un battito di ciglio
prima della fine della giornata della
mezzanotte ecco che se proviamo a
mettere le cose in prospettiva ea
immaginare di poter lavorare con un po
di coscienza critica sulle sul lungo
termine
anziché sul breve termine avere una
visione
la cosa improvvisamente appaiono
diversamente
e allora cosa bisogna fare
bisogna semplicemente tutti noi ad
operare la coscienza critica la
complessità abbandonarci a questo tempo
di incertezza con un po di sana
ipermetropia basta è sufficiente no
stamattina elia diceva non lasciate mai
che nessuno vi dica di no ecco vedete la
complessità di linguaggio la stessa
parola no può avere due significati
diametralmente opposti non basta avere
la coscienza critica domandarsi perché è
avere una visione ma bisogna attaccare a
quel perché un perché no altrimenti
perché da solo è un freno a mano
vi faccio un esempio stasera torneremo
tutti a casa i nostri compagni nei
nostri compagni e ci diranno magari
andiamo al cinema
provate a rispondere perché
si no freno a mano perché il sottotesto
in realtà è scusa eh
voglio solo togliermi le scarpe buttarmi
sul divano non so se c'è una partita ma
nel caso ci fosse non deve volare una
mosca
provate invece a dire perché no perché
no alla coscienza critica ma anche un
pizzico di sana incoscienza e curiosità
e la stessa sana incoscienza e curiosità
che ci ha fatto pensare di poter
addomesticare il fuoco e la stessa sana
incoscienza e curiosità
insieme alla nostra straordinaria
coscienza critica che ha fatto pensare
ad alcuni dei nostri antenati di poter
attraversare l'oceano e scoprire
l'australia o che ha fatto pensare ad
alcuni loro che valesse la pena di
salire in cima alla collina per vedere
un po più in là un po più in fondo è
come ormai abbiamo imparato tutti se
siamo ipermetropi in fondo si vede
meglio grazie
[Musica]